you can hear it yeah you always find the
[ __ ] up songs league god damn it
yeah that was a little slower do you
like the slower version i grew up
playing this version yeah but and and
i really love the feel of it because
this is like a 70s vibe which is what i
grew up playing you know 70s music you
know so it's got that really classic
rock vibe to it so by the time we
re-recorded the song
um the record company wanted more modern
so you know it has all these more of an
80s feel to it but still it's an awesome
blue song so what should i search for
the newer version
uh it's called slip of the tongue or or
steve bai it's steve i hope you're
loving because steve up playing guitar
on that one on the microphone mr rudy
sarzo the legendary rudy sarzo lisa
what's happening
i think i have it you're gonna play it
yeah yeah just
differences we're just [ __ ] around
holy [ __ ]
yeah oh [ __ ]
now you do everything over the vocals or
everything yeah from scratch
[ __ ] good enough for me
little shout out a little love for
stevie he's going through some hard
times right now
right he's going through a cancer right
now steve i know somebody's got cancer i
thought it was stevie vine maybe i'm oh
yeah but if he is not i think yeah i
just want to wish him yeah good luck
he's a dear friend you know and you know
he really takes greg
of himself he's a vegetarian vegan as a
matter of fact when we were playing
together and um white snake
uh he turned me on and i was a
vegetarian for five or six years you
know he turned me on into
uh not you know food combining or not
combining foods you know right in the
morning just having juice and not
combining your carbs
with your proteins you know so your food
digests better and stuff like that so he
really takes care of himself you know
more than anybody i know so maybe it's
not him i'm happy you're not a vegan no
more
cubans are not vegans
they try to slow it down a little bit
like when the cuban gets a heart attack
he'll switch it to turkey meat
and i'll switch the [ __ ] piccadilla
the turkey meat but that's as bad as i
get that's his [ __ ] that [ __ ]
what's up lisa how was your weekend
buddy it was good i uh you know what i'm
doing a lot now uh
i i've been on a diet for a female for
like six months and my girlfriend are
getting sick of it but i've lived in la
for like four years and i've never
really left the valley like other than
working down in santa monica i never
left
so we took the train down to japan town
or little tokyo in downtown we
we walked for like 20 minutes we found
this like revolving sushi bar like the
place that goes around on the conveyor
belt we walked around there we went to a
couple of japanese bakeries and stuff it
was a lot of fun something different
yeah i got out of the valley sometimes
because i mean i've lived here for years
and i haven't i've seen like less than
one percent of la so it was fun doing
that i'm stale i get stale i get really
stale that's why i like [ __ ] around
and going a long beach for the laugh
right because i'll sit i was just
telling these guys that i'll sit at home
not to lose a [ __ ] parking spot like
if it's between me losing this parking
spot let me come i'll stay home and
especially like tuesdays and thursdays
those [ __ ] double up on my
block once you leave that i don't even
know where these cars come from it's
like they pop from the ground up to some
[ __ ] right well i i i when i didn't have
a parking spot in my place i would never
i would never ever leave i don't know
how you do it sometimes how the [ __ ] i
do i had a great weekend i went to
portland oregon how was it [ __ ] shows
were great man i gotta tell you i lived
in the pacific northwest
and it's always had this little cool
feeling to it the pacific northwest you
know portland has really got it down you
know what portland reminds me of the old
houston comedy scene
like that people were involved in it
like the the people went to bars and
spoke about the guy performing they
didn't know his name just go down there
and wat let's watch him portland has
that feel to it they don't need to know
who you are or what tv show you're on or
know that [ __ ] that comes with comic
we heard you were funny we're gonna come
down here and check yeah you know
everybody brought me reefer and joints
and [ __ ] some guy brought the russian
kid brought blueberry cake that was just
brown from the thc and i gave it out to
the staff on friday night and everybody
got ripped i came the next day and the
manager's like you can't be giving this
[ __ ] up the workers here because the one
girl was on the floor sleeping back
there so it was uh did you ever hear
from the convenience store worker who
you gave the gummy to you gave the goomy
sharmano's gummy to like this poor lady
oh no no i haven't gone over that i
haven't gone over there to the to the
spot i'll go with it tomorrow i got to
meet somebody there for coffee so i'll
see you then but it was just a great
weekend i really like portland and
i want to thank everybody who came out i
want to thank lisa who left me uh
a little present for my daughter she
left me a beautiful little like uh
princess dress and a cute little shirt
and i want to always
thank
greg and lynn for always uh they dropped
off some edibles and whatnot so it was
pretty nice well it's really cool we our
guest is rudy sarzo and you guys were
talking before about vegas it must be
really cool when you're like you guys
travel for a living for a living and i'm
going to be looking i don't travel rudy
travel rudy got some freaking
[ __ ] flying miles back but you
get to go to like different cities and
like get like go there a lot and get to
know people and yeah you know it depends
on the band like uh when i was playing
uh with blue oyster cult that was the
last band that was doing a lot of a lot
of uh weekends you know you which
actually do make sense in today's
climate musical climate the fact that if
you can play thursday through sunday and
go home on monday and you know fly back
out again on thursday you're fine
because you know if you're going to be
playing any uh tuesday to wednesday
they're gonna be shed holes you know
they're they're those gigs that you're
just doing because you you know because
if you don't play
you're gonna be on the road staying in
hotels you know there's gonna be a tour
bus to pay for it's gonna be the crew to
pay for so you just want it's like a
shark you gotta keep it moving so it you
know so a ban is the same thing so if
you take
too many days off on the road you start
losing money
so my preferred way of touring unless
it's like you know a real you know
high-end type of band it's actually just
to do weekends because that you know
those are those are the prime gigs those
are the the uh the beam a market and you
know or b market and actually the b
market is what i consider now playing
casinos because when you're going into a
small town
all of a sudden you realize that there's
a casino right down the street and it's
actually one of one of the best gigs out
there you know do you do the same uh
location for the entire weekend or do
you go into an area and go like an hour
away each day no i've actually done
those the uh the residence you know okay
my i had a gig in in las vegas about
five years ago it was called monster
circus on the uh actually we were right
after barry manilow
on that elvis theater you know in the at
the hilton
and uh i loved it i loved it because you
know you just get up there and you're
staying at the hotel you fly in again it
was one of those weekend things you know
it was like from thursday until thursday
friday and saturday i think yeah
saturday sunday was the uh you know
four shows a week and the residents just
go home and you know have a
normal life how now
how is touring i was looking at you and
i'm going
jesus i'm going to ask rooney how is
touring changed in 20 years
[ __ ] it i saw rudy 31 years ago you saw
him play yeah 31 maybe right 83
well actually my three
my first tour was in 81 so that's like
33 81 yeah 81 i saw it whenever they
came to april to the palladium which is
a big show uh ozzie yeah
i just yeah i just mentioned and who you
were whistling yeah the jeff date
version of queen's right yeah okay yeah
it's it's so funny that how has it
changed in 33 years like when you first
started with quite right like saying
quite right open for ozzy for i know i'm
quiet right open for somebody for a
while do they not oh god we are we open
up for everybody from zz top to
scorpions to our maiden to lover boy
uh black sabbath uh judas priest now in
those days did you have a wife
uh no i that was 83 so i got married in
84.
so 81 how was touring then you toured
every [ __ ] because i remember like
looking at a band schedule
like for me
they would do philadelphia on wednesday
yeah
uh
newark
on
thursday
and then shoot into new york on friday
or saturday or yeah but i also know that
there was no like [ __ ] sunday through
thursday off you guys were right back at
it we were always on the road always
there was a circuit that you played the
a markets like were you talking about
the philadelphia's in the new york city
and and you know
new orleans
yeah you know but then we had the uh the
b markets we were towns that had hockey
arenas or b market you know like the
minor league hockey arenas those were
great venues
you know and so we would do all of those
you know and uh it was great because we
were really never off and you really
don't want it night off you know 33
years ago
having a night off meant that you were
going to wind up you know the next day
with a huge hangover because there's
nothing to do 33 years ago you check
into a holiday inn
it was a home box office which really
was a box it was a box with a rope
with three levels yeah and
you have basically hbo and whatever
channels they had you know local
channels that was it that was your
entertainment so your our our our
facebook was actually going down to to
the bar
you know to meet the fans and and the
crew and the other band that we were
touring with that was our social
networking was going down to the bar so
it meant that you went up the whole
night drinking you know and that really
affects you after a while you know being
on the road so uh
you know we had all those distractions
we don't have that anymore you know we
can actually be very creative because we
have all the technology available to us
you know the same technology that allows
our music to be stolen gives us the
freedom to create more
isn't that ironic
but it's it's weird how
i used to see those schedules like
how is touring chains i mean even with
me when i went on the road 15 years ago
i went on the road with one thing in
mind to do jokes and to get hot
to get [ __ ] up i i didn't know when i
was coming back yeah i had a plane
ticket for sunday at three in the
afternoon but i didn't know if i was
going to make that plane or not because
i was going deep on saturday night i was
going deep on friday night it didn't
matter to me if i got a movie it didn't
matter
and now
jesus christ i'm to the [ __ ] dime
like i'm for the dime like i gotta be on
a they're picking me up at 4 15 thursday
morning i'm in bed at 8 o'clock
wednesday night
you know i get off the plane i go
whatever i do to philadelphia i take a
shower i relax or in the old days i
would go right up i would just
throw my clothes in the [ __ ] room
and shoot out to do something that had
no meaning
no meeting until 6 30 and i go home take
a shower and go to the show then i
wonder why i'd bomb
why did you bomb because you haven't
relaxed your mind hasn't stopped you
haven't taken a minute for yourself i'd
go out that night get [ __ ] up and
that's the whole weekend there was no
creativity
there was no it was just doing the shows
i didn't even look at a notebook i
wouldn't even bring a notebook with me
how could you continue with your career
bombing
it was about it was a 50 50 shot
every night it was a 50 50 shot
and it didn't matter because after the
show i was going to get [ __ ] up and
get my dick sucked
so the bombing didn't really i was
bombing this was my mentality then i was
bombing in a place where it didn't
matter
i was trying out a new joke i wasn't i
wouldn't go it was just a horrible and
but then i got better and better
i got better about it and i would bring
a notebook and stuff and some nights i
would write coked up like i would
actually get coked up and write or make
believe i was writing
it was uh it really was a disaster and
then but i still made progress it was
or in my mind i thought i made progress
i started headlining obviously they
started headlining me i didn't take it
the addiction was the the whole thing to
get away from
at the time my girlfriend because i
couldn't get high around not that that
stopped me
but
it was just to get away from her to go
and get high i mean i used to do two
weeks in texas
from 2003 to 2006
or 2002 the club owner would headline me
over the holidays and i would do two
weeks
every night rudy
every night
i'm in my i just the other day just a
cold case was on
you know what show cold case that was on
for a while and i want one of the
episodes
i shot that on the monday after the
holidays you know that two-week break
you have yeah like i had to shoot that
like january 4th oh i came back that
january 3rd i wish you guys looked that
episode up and see how big i am
i had to be 420
that's when i was walking around at like
4 10
but after those two weeks i was just you
could see it you couldn't even see my
eyes
from the bloaty from being bloated from
all the eating salt eating restaurant
food french fries you know not taking
care of myself
and now it's completely different rudy
now it's completely different i got a
question for you because you know i
i used to play with sam kennison you
know we shared the same management i
played on his records we became friends
i went to a lot of his gigs and
what he used to do was at the end of the
show he would bring out a band right you
know most of his buddies you know kind
of like an all-star band we would do
wild thing i actually played played on
that record and i was in the video
and i remember him going out on stage
really messed up i mean like you know
drunk and
you know coke and
and he would bomb but people would still
show up it was crazy
you know maybe it was like to see a
train wreck or something it's like the
same thing who's the chick that died two
years ago i don't want to go to rehab
at the end you knew the [ __ ] was either
gonna cancel
be [ __ ] up sing a song and give you
the finger and leave
people still paid the 120 to go see
people love a train wreck is it
different with bands because with comedy
it's only you talking so like that would
be easier to tell if you were messed up
oh please yes and then but i would
imagine being [ __ ] up messes with with
you playing music it must oh yeah yeah
you can play and be screwed up no no
it's impossible um
especially if you're playing some
quality music you know i mean i can tell
you because i i
i experienced that i mean there was a
show in kansas city one time i was
playing with ozzy and
aussie used to like take to take b12
shots
so the promoter could only find a
dentist
that would come to administer the b12
shot to backstage you know so the guy
goes over to me on the side right before
i was going on stage and say hey you
want a bump and you have remember the
old days there were those little bottles
yeah yeah little carburetors it was like
like what do you call those it was like
a little bullet
oh and you turned the thing around
and then you turned it around again yeah
yeah i got a little boat yeah i go yeah
what the hell is a doctor
you know it must be someone for like you
know really good you know prescription
you know cocaine i guess you know
so i i did it was the only time that
i've ever did it you know
uh on you know
with ozzy going on stage and i'm telling
you i spent half the show i i just i
just wanted to like not die this time it
is awful it's terrible i i would with
all these problems i had i did have one
piece of
thing that kept me together march 17
1992 i got on stage coked up i never got
on stage cooked up ever again why do you
remember the date because i bombed that
bat
it was two different i thought that wait
a second if i do two lines i'm gonna get
chatty
and i'm gonna go up there and just chit
chat i'm gonna be [ __ ] great nobody's
figured this out yet richard bryant
figured it out saying kennison got it
and now i got it and i went on stage
because the cocaine cuts
your heart from your material
it cuts it that's why you can't be funny
yeah you'll get away with some jokes
there's some jerk off
they'll laugh
but you don't sell the joke the joke
isn't being sold it's just like reading
a book
so he went out and he whatever that's
what it felt like to me yeah i could
tell if i did too much coke the night
before it would affect my stand up even
if i didn't do coke the whole day
it would affect my standup i couldn't
control my mind was like a hangover
yeah it was like a hangover but it was
like a mental you can't you your heart
and your mind aren't connecting your
your mouth and your heart and your soul
are not connecting it's very weird to
explain see in addition to affecting
your your physically i mean your your
your you know your your emotions it
affects your your body it's like it
affects the the blood flow to your ears
so you start to hear more bass than
treble
and if you're on stage and somebody's
doing blow this is going to start
turning around and saying that you're
playing way too loud where you you're
just playing at the same volume as you
always play right and if you there's
certain
records that if you go back in the 70s
you listen to them and the bottom is
gone
it means that they spend they were they
were
they spent the night mixing those
records
and
to overcompensate they
lowered the base the you know the uh the
bottom end of the record so it sounds
like sizzling like
a lot of highs
they were on blood when they were mixing
that
you know and a lot of records were mixed
like that back in the 70s because you
know you had a uh a deadline you know
you have to like you spend so much time
recording and the regular company says
hey listen we're coming back tomorrow to
pick up the
the record the mix record and then we'll
take it and master it and then you know
release it so a lot of these guys were
under the gun you know and do because if
you're gonna do a mix a night
it's gonna take you two weeks to do it
and sometimes you just didn't have two
weeks you would have like maybe one week
so you're trying to compensate by just
doing staying up long enough to do two
mixes a day
like those
i just read
on youtube uh about a month ago they had
a campaign about volume four
the album black sabbath yeah and
what the
the whole part of it was that the first
four blacks album black sabbath times i
guess were recorded in one night
like the first one one night the second
one one night i don't know how true it
is whatever they were saying
how does that happen how do you [ __ ]
go into a star i mean i always wanted
your music easy easy easy because don't
you have to all right so let's say snow
blind all right rudy we're doing snow
blind one two three first of all we
don't even do it together yeah you lay
the bass first oh no no no how do you do
it ah not like that back in the day back
in the day a lot of the bands will go on
the road and they would do all these you
know they played everywhere back in the
day you you start your tour like in
stockholm or somewhere in scandinavia
and you do like a scandinavian tour
which means that you're testing your
material to go in the studio in a couple
of weeks right so you do all these tours
to get the band tied and get paid for it
that was like pre-production and then
you go in the studio and then you do
like one or two takes of each song and
you're done you're done like and then
in the days when people used to record
in the same room with uh with a really
good engineer that knew how to make
everything and and yeah
that that's the way it used to be done
no lay your track now lay your baseline
now so
like i read the the the one arrow smith
book the one from 98
when they talked about how much they
hated each other
and and 75 so
uh joe perry would go down and do the
guitar like they had to sign a sheet
they all lived in the same house
but they had to sign a sheet
to go into the recording studio one at a
time
they wouldn't get along so everybody
there's a drummer went so yeah did you
play the song first and everybody left
and then you redid your base lines and
he did his guitar was that how i was
done because i'm [ __ ] confused here
i'm blind listen all the like if you
if you read about the beatles they you
know the first record they did with
george martin they actually did that in
one day
they did you know so it and it was like
what 14 songs 15 songs because in
america we would get 10 songs per album
but in the in the uk release it was the
actually the full record the 15 songs or
whatever they happened to record you
know and uh
i i think that what happened was in
america uh engineers and producers are
they
they either got started getting picky or
lazy because the guys back in europe you
know in england all these english
engineers and producers they had it down
they knew i mean i worked with some of
those guys and then over look it got so
bad that you had to spend one day just
to get a snare sound back in the 70s
if you were going into uh to make a
record it was a given that the first day
was just drums and you would spend most
of the day just getting a stupid
snare sound come on you know just put if
you know if you know what you're doing
you just put maybe three mics the best
setups i've ever ever played with just
three mics one on the kick one of the
snare one overhead and that's it most of
the of the classic rock wreckers listen
to that's the way that they were
recorded and then either direct or or or
both you know you amp uh the uh you put
a mic on the on the base amp and direct
and then you know you get isolation
rooms you know all the students were
designed like that so you i isolate your
amplifiers or in the case of like where
the stones used to record you know they
they did exile on main street in uh in a
in a house that kev richards rented in
the south of france you know they took
the basement and they just you know make
baffles to separate the amplifiers and
that's how they did it you know and they
those are classic albums they have a
vibe they have soul to it you know we
were talking about the soul in your
material when you're delivering it
that's what's missing when you start
separating people and
you know one guy i do a lot of records
nowadays in my pajamas at home with my
little dog watching me because i'm they
send me the tracks
are they are they going to be timeless
records no
no
no to me a timeless record everybody has
to be in the same room to actu to record
that what is it is it like a feeling is
it like like kind of like the room has
like a like when oh like the band's
playing together is it like
right here right now we're experiencing
it okay we you and i we did a podcast um
it's way different this one because i'm
looking at you you're looking at me
we're communicating in the same room
you know it's not like me at home with
my telephone you know my cell phone
talking to you calling in okay yeah it
was good but it doesn't have that that
intimacy that we're having now
you know it's amazing we were talking
about
a band how you have so many different
personalities to deal with and you were
saying how lucky i was
uh because when you do comedy it's just
you in the microphone you just gotta
show up at a bar plug it in and [ __ ] it
you go crazy yeah for a guy like me when
i was growing up i read all those
magazines i read circus
and i read about recording sessions and
i had my dick used to get hard like just
you know the stones going to jamaica are
you [ __ ] kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me everybody going to jamaica
for two months
you know whether we like each other or
not we got a big bag of reefer we
[ __ ] get a couple black chicks and we
start you know whatever to me that was
phenomenal exile on main street now what
happened next it wasn't somebody old
money didn't somebody owe money that's
why they were hiding that's why they
were in france
somebody was looked for either keith
richards was looking at somebody was
looking for somebody you know i mean
there's a documentary about it and they
they touch on it lightly because it was
basically a documentary examination
documentary if you got netflix you can
watch it on that um it was basically
about the making of the record but you
know it was uh they were tax uh
right tax it was taxed yeah tax because
in england if you made a certain amount
of money
if you stayed in the country you had to
pay so much taxes so if you make the
record somewhere else you know you
you're not going to be hit with all
those taxes here do you prefer working
solo or with a group because
i i've worked with a few comedians and
comedians don't really tour that much
together some of them do but not really
it's like a single person i would
imagine with a five or six person group
yeah yeah comedy is more like boxing
yeah there's only two guys in the ring
at the time you know it's it's a men you
know one-on-one you know a uh
a band is really a team support
does it but how often does it go bad
like how often do people hate each other
and fight about money how many teams how
many name a sport i mean is there any
happy team no of course not i mean
there's something something going on
because everybody we're talking about
this that's the crazy factor
you have to be crazy to to do what you
do
joey i mean it's you know no i've always
known spoke to my wife about it last
night i was telling we were talking
about somebody and she goes
is that person joey d is crazy or the
other crazy and i go joey d is crazy
he's crazy but he's not like hearing
voices and shooting people i mean you
know to be crazy doesn't mean to be evil
right no no no no it's just like outside
of the box you know you're doing st you
got dreams and you just go for them you
know you're not going to listen to
to
everybody else telling you oh no because
you're you're whatever you are you're
never going to make it and
whatever so you leave town because you
want to get away from these people and
you wind up whatever you think the uh
the all the opportunities are to me it
was la you know because the record
companies were here and and all the
musicians that thought like-minded were
here so i joined a band and i slept on
the floor and i
you know and i did all this crazy [ __ ]
you know that if i look back now and go
oh my god
how did i have the balls to do all that
and i but i did you know and again if
you lose that edge that craziness
you're in trouble because you're gonna
you're not gonna
move forward you're not gonna progress
it's the craziness that will keep you
going forward getting better getting
crazier i always thought when i got off
drugs that my comedy was going to be
done
that was one of the reasons towards the
end i didn't want to get off the blow or
nothing
and then i thought about it i was like
wait a second i was always [ __ ] crazy
i just went to miami and i saw people
they were holding los santos mia for 35
years they held a bunch of my stuff
t-shirts and trophies and
and i went down and i started talking to
her and i said you know i was going to
your house in 148th street
and she goes whenever i met you she goes
out
she goes when you called i started
thinking about you you know and our
evolution you know she was 18 and i was
six when i met my godmother's daughter
we all got back together
and i used to go to 148th street and she
goes you were a quiet [ __ ] kid she
goes you built models
she goes you had a million [ __ ]
models
she goes you will lock yourself in a
room
and put on music and and build models
all [ __ ] day 10 hours three four
models in a day it was brilliant you
paint them and like this i don't
remember i really don't remember like a
little thing really and she goes but
then
you got hit in there with that lunch box
and that was the beginning of the end
she goes not that the lunch box made you
crazy you just didn't like it it brought
the real inside of you out you were
scared you were timid you didn't know
the language she goes but once they hit
you in the head with that lunch box that
day
everything changed
she goes you became aggressive you
became you got stitches and even in the
hospital i remember you told us that
night at dinner at your mother's bar you
said this will never happen to me again
nobody will ever hit me in the [ __ ]
head with a lunch box in fact i'm going
to hunt them down tomorrow and they all
looked at me like jose antonio
you can't go hunting these kids down in
central park
and i went to central park by myself and
then when i moved to jersey
i was so insecure about being cuban
that the first day i went out there was
a fight and i knew for me to get through
to these guys
i had to jump in that fight and stick up
for this kid that was getting beat up by
himself
as crazy as it was he was one kid
against eight
that's just crazy those are bruce lee
can't do that [ __ ] but in the back of my
mind i knew i knew for me to get into
this neighborhood
i had just come from new york city where
there was a couple spanish people
there's puerto ricans you know whatever
in the neighborhood i was moving to
north bergen new jersey in 1960 1970
there's not too many spanish people they
were in union city they were that way
and they were in west new york they
weren't in north bergen so that i lived
in that house for a year before i went
out do you know that
a year i lived in that house i would
always go to my mother's barn in the
city i wouldn't go play with the kids in
the neighborhood and my mom would tell
me
you got to go you got to go play
and one day i left with my white clothes
on because i used to dress up you know
my mom is dressed me in white with the
with the white sneakers with a gold
chain and i went around the corner i
heard them yelling and screaming and i
jumped in and backed that kid and my
life is i never looked back
i always had to follow that mentality i
always had to be
[ __ ] nuts but what people that know
us that i wasn't trying to be nuts i
really was [ __ ] nuts
you know it just came to me natural and
then as i got older i got
the cuban in me
and i worked very hard to get
that cuban man out of me the jealousy
the the quick reaction the hand
my hand would come up first i wouldn't
even give a [ __ ] i'd come flying through
a window i worked hard to get that out
of my system like i really had to work
hard to get the kubota even what do you
call it the gowanus or the assistant
because it was going to take me down it
still takes me down that's why i avoid a
lot of different situations you know
we're going to have steve burn on the
podcast here in a couple of weeks and he
called me this year asked me if i want
to do his show
and i thank them because i go the last
time i saw you i i was very crazy i went
at somebody at the comedy store
and as they were breaking us up i
remember looking and it was steve byrne
and looking at his face going holy [ __ ]
this guy's nuts
and my anger wasn't towards steve byrne
but him seeing me in that situation
always
made me very embarrassed in front of
steve byrne i never wanted to see steve
burn again if he wouldn't have called me
i wouldn't have been his friend anymore
because he saw me it's like the night i
stuck up for maryland my friend died and
somebody kept torturing her when she was
alive this [ __ ] producer from l.a and
at the wake he showed up to the weight
he had the balls to show for the weight
you know me doug that's my [ __ ] realm
i'm i'm from the world that i die if
you're gonna come you how are you gonna
bust somebody's balls when they're alive
then walk into his wake not when i'm
alive not on my [ __ ] clock and i went
off and that reputation followed me in
la people don't mess him because i went
off i made the guy leave i told him i'm
gonna get off the stage when i got off
the stage i'm gonna go you your attorney
and your wife and i meant it
i didn't care in my world where i come
from that's
i'm [ __ ] nuts but i work very hard
for people don't see that i work very
hard i avoid a lot of contact with
people
i already know this i knew this at 30.
i knew when i got out of prison that was
one thing for me to do what i was doing
as a comedian that i had to calm that
down because and that's why i avoid it
i avoid it number one number two when
something happens i attack that
situation right off the bat so it
doesn't either way at me can't eat away
at me because if i let either way you
know when i see you then it's gonna be
bad for you it's gonna be really [ __ ]
bad for you
so i can't let it eat away on me i
really can't i get [ __ ] hot so i
gotta call you your house and go hey dog
this is the situation and if you hang up
on me then i'm gonna go to the house and
light it on fire
that's how crazy i am that's how [ __ ]
nuts i am and it's just i don't want to
hit nobody i just don't want nobody
going idiot i don't like
i'm from old school you don't even if
what's the my favorite line and the
godfathers they should have met they
should have stopped hitting them in
munich
if they would have stopped the munich we
wouldn't have had this [ __ ] problem
but
and that's what i'm that's why i go
crazy and i've worked very hard to
eliminate that from my life you know
to eliminate that uh whatever so that's
the craziness i have but it's a thin
line
it's the same craziness that fueled me
to keep doing what i do
because
my thing that fuels me is i'm proving a
[ __ ] point to you
i'm proving a point that
when we went and told people that we
were going to be comedians
they told me i was a felon they told me
i was too old
they told me was too hard they told me a
thousand reasons why but i believed in
myself and i also believe that if they
knew about my life and who i was inside
it would help me and that's that
craziness is what keeps me waking up
every morning to prove my point that
anybody could do what the [ __ ] i do you
know everybody tells you you can't do
this you put limitations on yourself
just when i got in the car i was gonna
go to jiu jitsu
and in the car this morning i was
talking myself out of it already
talking myself out of it but then that
cuban voice
that says about that and all those bad
words came and i [ __ ] shot down the
beverly hills so that crazy you're right
that crazy is refused me what brought
the conversation up was we had lunch one
day and you had said to me that in the
music business
there's a thin line between mental
health and the artist
then it's the same thing in comedy i
mean you're right what makes somebody
get up and say i'm gonna [ __ ] live
three or four years in this life of
sleeping in floors
you know and everybody's done it if you
listen to guns and roses slag you know
aerosmith everybody's [ __ ] paid that
price but you gotta eat a bug one day
you gotta eat a coke snot that's it
that's all there is yeah that's it
yeah
but you know what
like like you
i've
you know i know you and
i used to hang out with sam kinnison and
a bunch of other um jimmy schubert
jamie schubert and comedians and all you
guys as crazy as you are you guys are
the nicest people most generous people
i've ever known sam was out of his mind
generous
i mean like beyond i mean it was like
embarrassing generous you know type of a
guy so it's
again going back to being crazy it's not
about being evil
not knowing any boundaries no boundaries
you know gives a [ __ ] you're limitless
to what you really want to achieve in
life you know
you there the night that sam and the
billy idol went on it oh god i was on
stage what a idea what the [ __ ]
caesar's palace
uh in las vegas
uh
is is very simple uh sam was you know
used to do two shows a night
so
on the first show
he hadn't gone to sleep for about two or
three days you know so we were up a
suite uh lenny bruce's uh uh mother mom
was there because she always hung out
with sam
and then you know and and the whole gang
the uh
mitchell walters yeah
alan stefan yeah stephanie yeah all of
the jimmy schubert and all those guys
and uh
so
sam used to bring on stage sabrina
and malayka
who became malayka became his wife and
sabrina was sister-in-law right and they
would be dressed like show girls you
know las vegas show girls outfits with
the feathers because they used to be
short girls before they met
so
we're on stage doing
playing uh wild thing
you know the song and billy idol is
there you know and he's on stage doing
his billy i don't think and he starts
grabbing malika and sam which has you
know he went nuts you know so we get off
the stage go back up to his uh
suite and he's like throwing [ __ ] around
and
he's just like
going insane saying next time on the
next set
i'm gonna [ __ ] dick up you know on
stage one you know all of that so
second show comes around and he does his
his comedy and then we do our our our
song and billy was gone but his his
sidekick
was there so sam just decked his friend
because he couldn't get to billy
and that was and that's what happened
caesar's palace
that must have been [ __ ] listen the
reason why i got into comedy was after i
read the lenny bruce book
i was wafering like i was wafering i
didn't know what i was gonna do with my
life i was leaning towards comedy but
once i read
ladies and gentlemen i knew it was for
me
and when i was seeing all that i mean
when i was watching sam go crazy
and i knew he had the outlaws and the
craziness and the [ __ ] hotels and the
crashing cars
that was another part that
lured me to this
craziness it really is craziness when
you were there when you were part of
this were you looking around saying to
yourself this is
just insane this guy's a comic yeah it
was playing [ __ ] music and it was
more insane than any musician that ever
been around
yeah
it was beyond rock and roll it was
comedian crazy
richard pryor stuff you know it was
level you know it wasn't yeah
and you're talking to a guy who was in
the same band with ozzy i played with
ozzy but no sam kinnison was more crazy
than
ozzy yeah i can't even imagine that yeah
yeah
this morning i was driving and they were
talking about the pink floyd album the
new pink floyd out did you hear it yet i
haven't listened to it
but the beauty of it was that two weeks
ago that [ __ ] roger waters
came up and said i have nothing to do
with this album you know
and you have in a band you have these
four people and there's always this one
little ego that floats around but he
controls it or he doesn't to me these
egos destroy the music business with
their craziness one is roger waters i
don't know
i
you know i've never met dave david
gilmour i don't know how crazy he is or
the rest of the guys i don't know what
happened but i know it when i think of
crazy ego i think of roger waters and i
think of
sting as much as i love sting as much as
i love the police you know
what i mean do you know i mean how the
[ __ ] does this happen
that your importance
because when i was thinking about like
sting for example like
so you're that important that you're
gonna break up this band
and take away from us fans
for your ego the same thing with roger
waters and then the [ __ ] guy goes you
know i don't know what david gilmore
said i don't know he goes to release
this island roger water says i have
nothing to do with this album that's
just now instrumentals right that's not
i don't even know if you know about it
that's it just you know people like that
is just i have never heard what the
voices in their heads are saying or what
they sound like so it's kind of hard for
me to be put myself in that position
because there's going to be some crazy
[ __ ] going on in his head
telling them [ __ ]
well don't i mean it's kind of talking
about asking earlier like if you were in
a band
not
maybe not you but don't don't think a
comedian since always by themselves like
if you were suddenly in a band with a
group of people
don't you think that ego would have the
same thing would happen i think i'm
surprised it doesn't happen more
i don't know
i got a question for you do you consider
yourself an artist
me yeah
yes and no
because that's a problem with musicians
or most of them who consider what this
is art what i'm doing and i'm not doing
it to please
the audience i'm doing to place my my
artistic
intentions or vision
do you ever go on stage like that
no
no never that's why i don't like the
word artist as much as it's used
especially in this town
especially in life i'm an artist so for
me when you say you're an artist that
means
you got a trust fund and your parents
send you money every month and you get
to try different [ __ ] every month yeah
that's what you're telling me you know
when somebody says artists my ears
always go up when i look over at a car
i'm at a coffee shop because that's
where i am that's what i yeah you just
mentioned yeah when i think of an artist
i think of van gogh right i saw one
painting to his brother
yeah one in his lifetime and cut his ear
off right no i think of if somebody
refers to themselves as that but i get
the art and i get to what i'm doing is
an art
and because of that maybe i'm an artist
because a stand-up is set up punchline
joke telling and storytelling
you know i i take that and i mix it
around that's the art yeah when you
learn to play the bass
but we learn to play instruments so we
can deliver a message and a message
there's a structure just like you have
in your storytelling right it's the same
thing with a song there's a structure to
it so there's
yes so there's definitely an art to
being a comedian you know because you're
telling a story
you're conveying you're putting a people
in a state
of hopefully happiness when you tell
your jokes and and from the moment
there's a middle
i mean there's a there's a beginning a
middle and an end to your act
so there's an artistry to it just like
being a musician but i don't think you
take it as seriously as a lot of these
guys no no no no no
no i i consider art like the first
instrument i ever played was the bass
i learned the past or music
you know i didn't like the bass because
it was boring as [ __ ] until i watched
you play it then i wanted to go sign up
again
do you understand me yeah it's your
that's what i call the largest your
interpretation of what i just showed you
there's a thousand front kicks
there's a thousand front kicks but the
way you throw it that's you hard was
because i i went to a lot of shows in
miami and i saw like miami was a really
a unique place to play back in the 70s
because it was either the beginning of
your tour or the end of the tour because
logistically uh a lot of the bands that
came from england you know europe and
england would come in and bring their
equipment through the port you know
florida dale miami port that's how they
brought their gear so they would either
begin the tour there and they would
rehearse
at the sportatorium for a week and you
know so you either saw the first show
which was really not the best
of their tour or you saw the last show
that traditionally last show with
english bands they used to pull all
these gags on each other they would like
throw whipped cream and get hit with
eggs during the set and stuff like that
so you either so either ways you were
going to see a pretty shitty show
because it was going to be the first
show or the last show of the set so i
saw a lot of boring performances from a
lot of guys that were really high
because
plus in addition to that was the drug
capital of the world
at that time in the 70s you know so they
were like i am blow heron or or or boos
or all of them at the same time so i i
said you know what i never want to be
one of these guys
you know the guys that just stood up
there and and just they were basically
like you know mannequins on stage
because they were so high not because
they were bad but they were they were
just so high at the time yeah
so that's why
it's [ __ ] crazy
see for a long time i thought they
started a lot of tours in philly for
years i would look at the schedules and
i would see tours starting in philly and
i thought it was because philly's such a
rough place to play you want to get it
out of the [ __ ] way that's what i
always thought i didn't know why because
i seen the stones in philly and it was
the first night of that door and i sent
ac dc at the palladium and it was the
second night of that door and they
started in philly so i'm like oh i never
even thought [ __ ] bands played in
miami
how hard is it to tour because i've been
lucky enough to go with joey for a
couple weekends and i'm not even
performing but leaving on thursday
morning coming back sunday morning i i
don't know i'm exhausted like i can't
imagine
doing
a month on a on a bus going to radio on
do you do radio or do are you just
sleeping all day and then doing the show
like what do you like it all depends the
the quality of people that you're
touring with as human beings if you can
really have fun and really respect and
vice versa they respect you you could
have the worst you could be playing the
worst shitholes but if you really love
the people and really love the music it
doesn't really matter what the
conditions are
i've been in some great traveling
conditions with with some tours that and
people that i have not i would just wish
and couldn't wait for it to be over
just because you know it to me the most
important thing is the quality of the
people that you're touring with really
not the accommodations
oh you're right you're absolutely right
what was the most fun you ended up tour
uh
no drugs just [ __ ] oh no guys
jamming and you know yeah i you know
it's nothing have to come close to
to the significance of of the blizzard
of oz diarrhea
with randy and ozzy well actually both
you know yeah and tommy yeah every night
on stage was the super bowl every single
night uh the quality and of course you
know we had the tragedy happen to us i
would say second will definitely be
either
white snake or deal because i really
love touring with ronnie
ronnie was
my god was he really from new jersey uh
no portland new york upstate new york
upstate
but he lived in new jersey or something
somebody said they saw him once in new
jersey i'm like come on yeah i i i
wouldn't doubt it doubt it because after
rainbow he came back to the us and and
lived in in the northeast you know
and then he moved back to l.a when he
then started black sabbath all of a
sudden you know after that
it's it's funny because you talk about
the super bowl or whatever
but on the other side of that i still
remember buying a cream magazine
and reading how black sabbath had just
broken up and
it
it was [ __ ] traumatizing like it was
just traumatizing i couldn't even
think
like yeah like led zeppelin then once
the jungle from like zeppelin died
there was a point where i was just lost
you know my mother had just died the
music and the reefer was everything and
all of a sudden you know black sabbath
broke up and
i'm reading this cream magazine in
february freezing my ass off that they
broke up and all of a sudden uh
john lennon gets shot you know when i go
to bleeker bob's in the city this
[ __ ] tremendous record store and i
find this ep by the blizzard of oz and
it's
four songs maybe you know 81 yeah and
i'm like what the [ __ ]
and listen to me and i'm telling you
guys this is that i don't know the
people i went with i could call them
right now and have them call in
you know this was everything to us well
you probably got the the uk
okay first i got the the four songs that
was in 1980 because that was yeah that
was in 81 that's when they actually
released blizzard blizzard in the states
so it was john lennon got shot december
8th
december so it was december or whatever
when i went to the city they were doing
something at strawberry fields whatever
i didn't go that way i went into the
village
in fact what did i go see
no that was a different i went to the
village and i got that that ep i just
found it by mistake it wasn't that i was
looking for it or i knew about it and
then
in cliffside park new jersey there's a
place called things from england they're
still steve
yeah
they're still there yeah it's in fact
you've seen it it's next to rudy's oh
he's [ __ ] rudy it's up the block well
the guy who won the play steve lang he
uh he passed away a few years ago but he
was a really good friend of my brother
robert and me he's still open yes it's
still open yeah
i think that's where i bought the aussie
tickets that's where i would buy
everything because he always used to buy
a block for himself yeah so he'd tell
you if you're in a bind come up and i'll
try to hook you up i know friends great
guy great guy this is [ __ ] crazy but
i just said that things from england i
bought so many things there
i bought so many like uk releases there
you know as a child like anything from
ufo i bought tons of [ __ ] even if it's
20 more than the regular album i tell
them to put it away to the side there
was no [ __ ] layaway then you just
looked him in the eye and said dog
put that away i'll be here sunday if you
don't hear sunday by one i'll sell it
he'd sell it
things from [ __ ] england that's
amazing how has or do you think that
world still exists because now with
digital
like people just go online and buy like
do
does that even still exist you go to a
store i find i find that people usually
download stuff that they will never buy
anyways
if you're going to buy something it's
because you're a collector and your
heart is into it so you're going to buy
it uh
i talk to i talk to a lot of kids and
they say you know just like download it
because i want to see what it's all
about and they're really not into it
they're kids they didn't grow up with
that music they're stealing music
that they didn't grow up with there so
they don't have any emotional connection
with it to them it's just like uh let me
check this out it's like us listening to
the radio you know and they will not buy
it anyways
but even with like even if they are
buying it on itunes like it's not like
going to that record store and just what
is this record
well first of all it's
a it's a digital download it's never
going to sound as good as an actual lp
is with the right equipment
you know so
yeah there's
there's pros and cons about it i mean of
course you know we've gotten used to
hearing certain things like
i i have a couple of phonograph systems
at home you know lp play i know i never
i
don't like someone that'll play a record
i couldn't even remember the last time i
played her and actually albums yeah yeah
i just never taken one out and put it on
no
well let me tell you the flip side of
that the flip side of it as a fan
as a real fan as a [ __ ] fan of the
music
there's nothing like going home
putting the arm on and reading that
album
to me that was an hour of my day with
tears in my eyes the whole [ __ ] time
i'd be listening to that i'm reading the
cover thank you to the charities you
know i didn't give a [ __ ] i knew the
recording engineers i knew the tour
managers because there was nothing like
opening up an album and taking the
poster out and it was david lee roth on
van halen too and i ripped it up that
[ __ ] sucked it was chained like that i
didn't like it but the point is the
point is that i there was something
about that when i download uh you know
uh white snake on my ipod that's it
that's it
the mysticism the whole thing about the
music to be strictly honest with you i
bought sabotage next to
the wingfun chinese restaurant used to
have a little music store in north
bergen new york new jersey i remember
that you couldn't wait to get home with
this [ __ ] album and let me tell you
something let me tell you something you
had a better chance of stabbing my
mother in the neck than taking this
[ __ ] album from me or then looking at
this album because while it had the
paper on it nobody was going to look at
this [ __ ] arm let me see it no
there's nothing to say no i think
you don't got to see nothing here come
over later after i listen to it i'm
going to look at this album first you
take it home there was nothing like
taking that album out putting it on and
if it was a thing that helmet you roll
the joint in there if you people say
that today they still go to old album
places and they open it up and they see
seeds and albums and [ __ ] because that's
what you did you cleaned your seeds out
the seeds would roll and then you'd roll
your joint you'd smoke it and you'd read
the [ __ ] album and you listened to
the album two or three times then you
went out and talked [ __ ] about the album
there was no internet to [ __ ] go on
and say rudy's album is good or
oh it's tremendous there was no
commercials in the 70s that said get
white no
it was word of mouth you went to the
basketball court dog i got the new
[ __ ] rainbow album oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i
gotta borrow it you ain't borrowing [ __ ]
[ __ ] stop being so cheap go buy a
[ __ ] album you know that's how it was
that's the they've removed that
even if i buy your [ __ ] dvd i open it
up and it's a sheet of paper
they don't even have that anymore no i
want to see something read me something
give me the lyrics to the song
give me something you know i i tell
people that the whole if you open up in
through the outdoor led zeppelin's last
down you take the album
the [ __ ] sleeve you get a sponge
you wet the sponge then you you squeeze
that sponge and you go like that and
also the pills and everything will pop
up to life they're all different colors
they did things to make you if you open
up there were like like four different
versions different versions yeah yeah if
you opened up some girls some girls was
brilliant yeah by the stones because you
moved the heads yeah so there was all
these advertising for wigs and you moved
the faces of the stones yeah led
zeppelin 3 was a thing you spun around
inside the album yeah how much would an
album cost 7.99 okay 8.99
this [ __ ] 20 million that's unheard
of it was about the fans it was about
them it was about everybody made a
little bit of [ __ ] money everybody
made a little bit of money everybody was
[ __ ] happy world record companies
made a lot of made a lot of money money
i spent 20 dollars for him and ozzy
osbourne 25 at the palladium
for tickets i paid 15.50
for pink floyd the wall in 1980 at
nassau coliseum why would i give you 250
and go to [ __ ] the hollywood bowl to
sit there like a mutt
when people would kill themselves when
people were fans of the music
fans i mean when you're on stage you
[ __ ] cried you [ __ ] cried you were
like god damn i'm here that's what it
was like
i don't see that anymore but i'm not
young anymore you know the only place i
see that and i'm not a fan of the music
but like you know those like boy bands
like one direction and and like how
those like young girls are with like
those kind of bands so is that is that
kind of good i mean in a way
you're talking about the beatles with
chicks are jumping up and down and
yelling and fainting
i'm talking about guys going to see you
know at the end of uh almost famous when
she goes off on
on the [ __ ] kid
she goes off on the guy
she says a beautiful [ __ ] speech
about
the fans
it was about the [ __ ] fans man
it was a beautiful thing when you went
to these shows it was it was the biggest
thing in my going to see you at the
palladium was the biggest thing in my
world when i found out you were cuban
you gave me hope man
i knew i could do something in my life
i'd have to stab people or sell
nickelbacks in eating city you know
you know i've been a fan longer than
i've been a professional musician
and there will come a day that i will
stop being in professional musician
because you know it'd be freaking old to
be doing this but i can guarantee you
i'll never stop being a fan i'm a fan i
can't believe it i couldn't be a
musician if if i was not a fan it would
be impossible how can you be a musician
if you're not a fan of of of
what you're
what you
risk everything in life for
i when i go see a band
and i listen to songs i'm watching them
i'm thinking about all the effort i
wanted to put and that's how i felt when
i was first
yeah when i was 15 i knew the effort
that it took to do that because i wasn't
doing it i tried singing in the shower
and i failed
never mind i knew the effort i don't
know why not only the effort but look at
the sacrifices because you know it's
i'm not i'm i'm not making
stuff up here i'll give you an example
black sabbath and i'm going to give you
information that came down to me from
from aussie you know stuff that it was
sitting around in the bus talking about
you know they were kids they were kids
who
one day they went to a theater saw a
scary movie and figure out hey if we can
make music that is scary as what the
movie that we saw we're on to something
so they went from being called uh
earth yeah to being called black sabbath
that was like the okay we're going to be
scary so they started
creating scary music and scary things
there were still kids out of uh
birmingham in england they were trying
to find a way how to get out of that not
have to be in the factory you know how
tony oyomy lost his finger this is what
ozzie told me um he was uh he was
working with at a factory with his dad
in one of those press machines uh it
jumped his finger you know off and his
father took him to emergency and the
doctor said listen we you know i can uh
attach the finger
and the father said how long would that
take to heal and says well it's going to
be a few weeks and his father said how
about if we just leave it off and say oh
yeah he can go back to work immediately
that was the decision deciding factor of
him not having the full finger and
having to have a whatever you know
little plastic thing but then again it
changed the sound of music
he would never sound the same
with the full hand you know what i mean
it just changed everything so out of out
of that came this new sound this black
savage sound you know he played a
different way
and and
we started connecting emotionally with
it right meanwhile these guys were
managed the manager that they had in
those days they never saw any money they
just would put them on the right no this
before dawn wow wait wait the original
guy before dawn
uh
it's just like if if let's say if you
were ozzy and you went to the office
says hey listen i haven't seen any money
you know we just got off the road the
guy we
opened the drawer pull up some keys and
said yeah you see the cadillac yeah it's
yours now they weren't aware that they
were already paying for that cadillac
anyways but that was kind of like okay
well i got something out of it and the
guy would just leave meanwhile all these
guys were making
money money that the musicians never saw
and they just kept them on the road kept
them
you know
i i've worked with some people in the
industry that
they make you think that you're working
for management no the band hires the
manager the manager any the bandit at
any time say listen you guys take a hike
you know there's going to be some
contracts and some certain things that
you're going to owe them just like in in
any industry whether you if you're a
comedian or an actor you have a certain
management agreement and you know the
guy is taking you so far in your career
and then you
that you know you disconnect from that
person but still you owe them you know
some royalties or whatever it's the same
thing in music but in music they always
made you feel like oh you guys are
nothing with us managers you know which
was not the case so they always kept
things away from you they never allowed
you to hang out with the record company
people
if they you know by them you and the
record company people no no no they had
to be there
to make sure that they were the buffer
they were the
the filter for you to get to the record
company because if they figure if you
realize that you really don't need these
guys
they're done they don't have a job so
they always make it look like oh yeah
well you know we're going to keep you
guys on the road uh do you need anything
like some pot some some cocaine okay
i'll send you some on the road and
that's how bands you know were treated
back then
before they got smart nowadays it's very
rare that you see that happen to any
band
well
when you are a musician
the ego was built by money
you know uh sting didn't [ __ ] get up
and leave one day when there were three
little dirty kids
playing music everybody was in love
it's when money gets involved
that it makes it breaks up bands that
when you're just a kid you're just
excited to be playing rudy sarzo in
front of people in the garage who the
[ __ ] are you kidding if i give you ten
dollars in a joint
really and i gave you a bed that's a lot
better than you were doing at home
so
i mean i just want to do when i first
started doing comics i just want to do
comedy you know when i hate comedy
now when i got to deal with money
i wish i didn't have to deal with money
i would love comedy that's when this is
great
it's when money starts coming in that
people egos attitudes get shitty
what the [ __ ] you know
i just watched that documentary again
about the eagles you know they went to
them one day and said this is so us
three we're making all the money and
you're sitting at home and you don't get
no money
i can't see that either i can't see that
either that's five guys we're a band but
you're not giving me all the money and i
wrote the [ __ ] rift to hotel
california what are you talking about
what are you talking about i'm a paid
salary so that's one thing
that's complicated about the ban that i
would have shot everybody in the bank
now i know why you know yeah it's tough
that's tough the money thing is very
tough yeah and it's it's the manager's
job or whoever is in charge of being the
uh
the counselor for the musicians where it
could be a lawyer because a lot of bands
actually have a lawyer and rather than
to have a management that they have to
give him a commission it's up to these
individuals to be the clear heads
because clear heads will prevail in a
situation like that rarely do you see it
happen
rarely the powers that be side with
whoever has the most power within the
band whether it's the guy who wrote the
songs or the guy who was the most
popular have the biggest fan base or
anything like that
rarely do you see somebody coming in and
saying listen guys let's sit down and
make this and work this out because once
to be honest with you i in certain
situations i've tried to be that guy
and
with not much success but at least i
knew that i couldn't go to sleep
if i just let it fall apart without me
trying to be reasonable and say listen
why don't we work this out
you know and of course
it did not get worked out but
nevertheless yeah people it's people
like that that really make make a
difference because
again thinking of the fan
as a fan if i grew up with certain bands
and once they started changing the the
the personnel you know the band members
it wasn't the same band anymore i wasn't
into the band anymore because it was
kind of like i grew up with lifers and
teams like mickey mantle was a yankee
his whole life you know bobby richardson
all these guys tony cubic it wasn't like
they were you know they were with the
yankees today and then they were with
boston the next year and stuff like that
i truly believe in and people who are
members of the group for you know for
their entire career and this is coming
from a guy who's played with many bands
but it was never my intention to do that
it's just happened but ideally yeah i
would have rather been with just one
band
of course
i didn't have any
aspirations of moving forward or you
know moving on to something else when i
first started doing this no of course
not i've been married for over 33 years
now uh 30 31 years
you know so it's i wish i would have had
the same type of music career
you know
for life
five
same five guys
let's say somebody passes on like it
happened with brian jones even though
brian jones was out of the band you know
by the time you know and then he passed
away but you know things like that you
know just the same five guys you know
four guys whatever you know
and uh yeah that was my intention i
think about a band like led zeppelin
who had nine albums these are guys that
were you know
that problems that drug problems the
singer lost a kid
there were problems there
how many bands today do you see with
nine albums
none i don't know
how many how many [ __ ] bands a bad
company had a couple albums too seven or
eight yeah yeah
you don't see bands like that no
the beatles had 90 [ __ ] albums i mean
yeah tony bennett's got 60 albums but
he's by himself yeah you know every once
in a while he duets with lady gaga some
[ __ ] but besides that you know
it's it's i i've always been a fan of
bands and music and what comes along
like i said
i would love i would be that guy that
just rolls joints
on the [ __ ] tour like when the stones
did some in jamaica or something just to
see the process do you write your own
music rudy yeah i do and how is the
process from
a
to the album i mean how does that work
it's you by yourself well it's it's a
matter of writing the music and then
convincing everybody else that
it should go on the record
which is the toughest part part of them
all yeah because if you're not the
singer the singer is gonna gravitate
towards the music that they write
because
it's it it just makes sense it's like
telling a singer
sing this melody is like a singer
telling me play this bass part
you know what i mean so it's it's you're
you're you're getting into their
territory so the best thing you had the
second best thing you can do is to
actually call it and collaborate
with the guys or the singer because
again you know you're gonna have vocals
and you're gonna have melody you know
vocal melodies and lyrics and the song
so if you can actually collaborate with
the singer and let him come up with you
know whatever he feels comfortable
and or the message that they're gonna
deliver then you're on on the right
track
is that like the hardest part do you
think because i know i used to be an
editor on tv and
i hated even though you can't really
admit it because it's part of being
professional but i hated when i would
come up with something and then a
producer would come in
and say oh i don't like that so it like
let's say you were you were pitching
your song and they wanted to change or
they didn't like it
what it like that feeling must be
terrible that it's like the worst i
would imagine it's the worst yeah it's
one of those things that you have to
just leave your ego out
and just unders you know
what's best for the for the big picture
no matter how
screwed up the big picture might be
you know you just go with you know a lot
of times you're gonna have to go with
the flow you know of the end with the
individuals and it's uh it's tough
it's tough it's like you imagine you
trying to what you're gonna be doing
tomorrow night
three other guys and you're gonna talk
them to them into like okay this joke
that joke you you tell this other joke
and you do it this way
can you imagine that
it's a pain in the ass
i was watching the
mr james brown oh yeah
mr dynamite with mick jagger when he oh
the movie yeah yeah yeah no not the
movie the one the the documentary it's
playing now
they know that oh yeah they you haven't
seen them
no and they told mick jagger that 1965
mick jagger was watching james brown on
the sidelines they were doing a show
together yeah and i guess the stones
were headlining it yeah james brown
wanted to kill him because he wanted a
headline yeah he couldn't understand
that like it's a tv show grandma yeah
but they said when james brought on the
state went on the stage that mick jagger
was in the sidelines traumatized and in
shock yeah from when they showed did you
see it i saw they they had that scene in
the movie that just came out and like
james was like follow that welcome to
america yeah he blew them off stage oh
my god and that's when mick jagger says
that's [ __ ] he goes as a matter of
fact it was a different audience
they had came in and changed the sound
oh the band it was [ __ ] it was a
complete different audience i don't know
why they said that he goes yes his
performance was they showed it
if you watch the documentary they show
the stones
and they showed this show james brown
and james brown just took it to a
different [ __ ] level altogether and
they showed mick jagger putting it
together but no he didn't well i mean
you have james brown who's the real deal
and you got a bunch of white kids from
england
who were influenced by james brown and
and all the uh you know all the blues
players and all of that so you have like
second generation so but just like elvis
and all the other white artists could
they could actually relate to the white
kids
better
than
you know an afro-american musician could
even those african-american musicians
were brilliant oh they were the best
really the best the best the nothing
came close nothing no well it's the real
deal listen uh david ruffin from the
temptations to me yeah has one of the
greatest voices of all time the problem
with it was drugs too and he was [ __ ]
crazy but the temptations uh
you know and they were all from jersey
like they were all like if you really
look into it all those labels all those
kids were from jersey and i heard those
songs i forget the one this magic moment
that guy's voice
i don't know who's saying that
jay and the americans jay black yeah are
you [ __ ] kidding me that that is just
i mean are they black well the only
thing black about him is his last name
tony's better
we do this every monday is my mother's
favorite song
when they came from cuba
what's up [ __ ]
nothing let me give some shout out to
you
my man uh like i said greg and lynn
thank you very much coming to the show
and
give me the involved they're gonna mail
something for you lee they had something
for you and lisa again thank you very
much
for the special gift from my daughter
nathan james turner
i love you [ __ ] ahmad al-ahmed
stay black mitchell convey
derek jewell cleo happy birthday you
know we love you here mr whiskey you're
a bad [ __ ]
amy xp dj i love you buddy brandi lynn
hang in there you dirty [ __ ]
now what's the pr project rock talk to
me about project rock oh project rock
it's it's well
now it's being rebranded something else
but it was just basically
a bunch of friends you know guys that i
play with that i that i know from other
bands like tim ripper owens you know he
was wasn't jewish priest when alfred was
out of the band as a matter of fact they
you know that movie uh rockstar is based
on his story
you know he did an interview with some
journalists and some magazine and
somebody took the story of him being
just a kid that replaced this superstar
you know rob alford
from um jewish priests and you know
frozen when we went from a tribute band
to actually being in the real band and
they made a movie out of that story so
uh but he's an incredible singer and
then you know with guys like teddy uh
zigzag who play with guns and roses
uh keyboard player and james call attack
drummer from scorpions and kerry kelly
who played with alice cooper and we
would just go to russia deep deep deep
into russia siberia kancheka you know
whatever you know not not was considered
san francisco in in la which is saint
petersburg and moscow we really went in
deep in there
and just bring music to the fans you
know these are
we're talking about what it's been 20 25
years since the uh the fall of the
berlin wall you know
and
this is a whole different russia you
know forget about putin and all the
conflicts going on you know politically
let's talk about the people people are
just fantastic and they love america
music and they love rock and roll
and
one of the things the reason why they
love it is because it was the music that
they were not allowed
to watch
there were no rock performers during the
cold war and or music you know it was
all clandestine you know you have to
like
you know go in a basement listen to the
music with your headphones and
all of that you know it was
yeah you
you
you made sacrifices a lot of people went
to jail went to siberia because of you
know
embracing american music
and one of the things that i found that
was really interesting was and i and i
and i
i noticed this because you know being
from cuba
i was exposed to afro cuban music afro
being the key word then when i came to
the united states i started listening to
blues
and then i was exposed to african
blues you know which is where it comes
from and i'm going
my goodness this music latin music and
blues come from the same place africa
you know and they brought here through
you know the slaves
i don't know you know it's it's a it's a
terrible period you know in history but
that's how that's how we got our
american music you know through that
um one of the things you have to take
into consideration is that the slaves in
in the caribbean were allowed to play
their percussion instruments because you
know they were in spanish
plantations you know
whereas the plantations in the united
states outside of
louisiana which was french
they were not allowed to
use their percussion instruments so they
as as
as a way to survive
their
sacrifice you know the hardships of
working in in the fields they would sing
you know and if you listen to kiwi to
traditional cuban music and the blues is
all 145 progressions you know it's the
same format
you know and
and
i'm looking at it and saying wow how
rich are the music of the united states
is
you know that came out of this
this
terrible
terrible
times in in our history you know with
through slavery
and
and i think about
not only that
as
but you know us as individuals when we
go through bad times
you know if you look at a diamond
it's because it's being compressed
we get our lives become compressed
and the ones that can actually survive
that compression
we at the end of it we come up like
diamonds
so if you listen to an american music
you listen to the blues you listen to
jazz
all of that
it was a
a culture a people that were compressed
the heart that
their lives were so hard
that at the end of it the diamond that
came out was actually music
american music it's the most
true form of american music that there
is jazz rock and roll blues r b gospel
you know the
the uh
the the soulful gospel that we that we
know you know where singers such as uh
aretha franklin came from and so on
and uh
this is something that the rest of the
world does not have in common with us if
you go to russia there's no
african artists
that have
that influence in them you know i mean
it's not part of their culture so when
they listen to the blues they're hearing
something that yes it's about hope and
faith because that's what's happening in
in the field when you know when they
were working you know under such
conditions you know the hope and the
faith that someday all of this was going
to end and they were going to lead
better lives
that is universal
and you can hear in the music and you
can hear it
even
really in the music in the notes that
are being played all the pentatonic
blues you know scales and riffs and
everything that comes through that music
and when you take that to a country
such as russia that had their own period
of hope and faith through music to be
able to survive their lives
they connect with it in a way that
even most of americans today
cannot connect with because right now
we're connecting with electronic music
music created by computers
that's our reference that's our
connection we're losing soul
we're losing our our connection with our
heart and our soul and our spirituality
even because this is if you if you
listen to blues and jazz it's very
spiritual music because that's where it
came from
spirituality
so then again going back to russia
uh
one of the things that that i learned
from traveling there is that all of
these dictators communist dictators they
had they were smart enough not to
interfere with their faith
they knew that they could not fight
god
so they let them they turn like a blind
eye to it and just let them keep their
churches and keep their their faith and
so when you travel through all these
little towns the most beautiful
ornate buildings well-kept is the actual
church the local church
you know they're very spiritual people
very
this it's it reminds me of cubans
you know it's like this very tight knit
uh culture people really relate to each
other they help each other out and
they're very communicative with each
other
you blew my mind
sometimes people blow my mind you blow
my mind with that one you just brought
it up what do you
what is your position on electronic
music like sampling and all that that's
going on right now you know any form of
expression it's it's i mean if a human
being can come out with like you know
making music with uh with farts and it
sells and people go for it i'm not gonna
judge that
but to me what really moves me really
touches what makes the the hairs in my
arm you know stand
it's when it touches my soul and so far
you know electronic music doesn't do
that to me but then again you know
you're talking about events uh edm
they're very
popular with the type of people who are
looking after
a certain
experience
you know and most of them happen to be
you know they're they're induced by some
kind of chemical
you know yeah it's it is what it is i'm
not making this up you know and ecstasy
or whatever so it is an event it's a
social cultural event and you know to be
honest with you if i would have known
40 years ago that i could actually get a
laptop
and go up there and make millions of
dollars
the hell would play the base
it's a good way of looking at that you
know i don't even know what electronic
music is
well from what i know how bad am i how
bad am i people i'm sorry i just don't
even know what it is i don't know what
it sounds like i don't know if it sounds
the same
i think there's a difference because i
know russell peters gets mad about it
there's a difference between some people
go and grab old records and get loops
and create music with actual old music
but then i think some of these other
electronic music people are just like
solely with their computer they're not
they're not going and actually finding
the loops and like it's kind of what
you're talking about when you're talking
about the engineers and the the ones who
really know what they're doing that
i really like that because i'm a very
techy person
and
i would love to go see an old engineer
in the old studio not with a computer
but with like the actual analog material
who actually knows what he's doing so
like a great dj who can go and pick up a
record and mix it together and make her
sound really awesome i like that but
then again i understand like the
the dislike of just going on the
computer and basically mashing it
together yeah you know and this is sort
of an art to that uh
yeah
uh basically because you know
music music it's supposed to move you
it's supposed to affect you you know
emotionally and put you in a certain
state
and if electronic music can do that to a
human being there you go that's the the
individual has accomplished that um
what i what's missing to me in
electronic you know edm electronic dance
music it's the message
and i think
is since there is no message the
individual can create their own message
rather than to hear a song
and even do there might be certain
metaphors you know
i mean i know that there's writers that
don't realize what their song is about
but there is a message in there that
becomes your message but then when music
is delivered that intentionally there is
no message whatsoever
then you're forced to create it yourself
and this to me is what edm
does
it's a you fill in the blanks as a human
being how is this music touching you
what are you getting out of it you know
how's it making you feel which is the
most important thing about music
especially if you're under ecstasy
those events are huge
were like 100 000 people you know
you know you know when that stuff came
up i was a little older long in the
tooth
you know i would go to more con i would
go to more concerts now like last week
ray canella my friend came from jersey i
had abandoned the sixth grade we had a
band we played the beatles help
from beginning to end that's all we did
we lip synced yeah and uh
then we went loose you know we we do a
janet jackson yeah we start off with the
album and then we played live and uh
he went to see judas priest yeah and i
called him the next day how were they
and he loved him he loved the new
guitarist he loved the
the kk dog tipped and i think kk's gone
yeah
and he said alfred sounded great yeah
the whole thing and i love all that
stuff and it's weird i would go to that
every other night
but it's such a [ __ ] pain in the ass
really you know
you know i think when i was a kid it was
easier when i was younger i would take
the train and drink some beers yeah but
i gotta tell you
the importance of that
uh
and i i had an experience uh recently uh
back in 1983 quinn riot opened up for
for judas priest in england so i got to
watch him every single night spectacular
exactly
then you forget you forget you know and
life goes on you know and then recently
uh the whole band uh judas priest did a
rock and roll fantasy camp
and
howefer you know he had just had some
back surgery and stuff like that so it
was taking it easy
i'm going to tell you when these guys
the real deal opened their mouth and we
were just talking about james brown well
you know rob halfer in the metal world
he is the real deal
yeah when he opened his mouth and he
sing you're like
i don't care who's in the tribute band
who's doing this and that there's only
one rug
it's
and there's something about everything
yeah let me rephrase that it's not
something
everything
about his singing his voice
is the real deal
and he does stuff that you have never
heard or probably might never hear
anybody else do
it's so
it's
he's like nobody else
and what's going to happen is someday
hopefully not soon but eventually
just like many other voices like i've
worked with you know
ronnie james deal
another incredible voice one of a kind
they're no longer with us
maybe because he's still alive but he
cannot perform anymore or decides not to
perform anymore
so to me anytime that any of these
artists the real deal comes around you
gotta go you gotta go
you gotta go because it's not only might
be the last time but it's a reminder you
must remind yourself of what the real
deal really is all about what it sounds
like
what it looks like
you and you have to hear it for yourself
right there in person
a lot of i've heard a lot of comedians
say they don't like going to see other
comedians because they don't want to get
influenced and steal a joke
or by mistake copy a joke or just be
influenced do you still go see music i'm
a fan i'm a fan i must
i must and it doesn't really seem like
it's that big of an issue in music to be
influenced by other musicians it seems
like everybody is and they don't like
cons it's not as bad as like joke
stealing you should be influenced by
everybody
uh absolutely everybody has something
that's so unique about them truly if
you're dealing especially the real deal
guys
yeah i mean i you know guys that might
not even be known for like being fast or
or whatever or heavy
oh boy yeah maybe it's the the groove
the pocket
you have to you have to have a groove to
your plane you know otherwise there's
this this is [ __ ] stephen
a dear friend of mine
put children of the grave on my facebook
page the other night from 1974 at the
california jam
i was listening to the right uh this
morning this morning what is the name of
it children of the grave 1974 california
gym first of all ozzy osmond was ozzie
it was john osborne yeah that's when he
was i was actually watching the video
doesn't it
because somebody posted it that's what
yeah yeah
my buddy from jersey posted and i
and watched that and i was [ __ ]
blown the [ __ ] away
it's 1974. no
high-level technology here this is just
for [ __ ] guys how [ __ ] crazy those
geezers it's like the daytime too yeah
that's when they did concerts california
look at the people the amount of people
what are you clocking at how many people
are there
um
it's like a whole it looks like
woodstock how about you understand
yeah yeah
and we did the uh
we did the us festival in 83 that was
350 000.
so that must have been about 175 200.
yeah
just amazing
i would and then they have another one
of them doing something on on don
cursor's rock concert midnight special
yeah then a black sabbath and there's
two guys with matching shirts just
losing their [ __ ] head it's it's it's
mine i love all that stuff so it's
called black sabbath children of the
grave of 1974 california but then again
you know i once black sabbath came
around last year i went to see them at
the exploratorium how were they the real
deal again they were actually i thought
they were better than i've ever seen
ozzy and and the guys because i you know
i i play with ozzy and then about
the following year with quiet ride we
open up for black sabbath on their uh uh
unborn was that the um
1983 they had the like the little the
little devil on
born again born again born again with
ian gillan on vocals did you go see them
do you want to see him this last time
yeah phenomenal
everybody said they were phenomenal just
phenomenal everybody phenomenal better
than i mean better than i've ever seen
them you know everybody talks about john
gotti and
i think the baddest [ __ ] guinea
ever is tony me naomi i say i love him
i love him let me read the responses and
i'll get you the hell out of here listen
man
it's always the problem with you i don't
have 10 hours
i wish i had 10 hours you know because i
consider you the real deal you're the
the [ __ ] you're too much savage
and it's crazy that we have uh
you know the cuban thing between us
because i love it it makes me today i
met another today i went to jiu jitsu
yeah and i get it and some kid comes
right over and he goes home without me
family
you know and i go you have [ __ ]
feebles that's like a weird cube in
there i go you have family and then he
goes yeah how'd you know i go i hang out
with danny he goes oh my god my uncle's
got cancer we started talking
and more and more he goes i listen to
the podcast and then uh
he's a fireman you know he talked and on
the way out he gave me a dick van dyke
book he knows that i learned how to
speak english when i came from cuba
watching dick van dyke yeah that was my
shot i learned to speak english
and uh he gave me the book and he goes
this is for you for all the excitement
you bring me on the podcast he goes one
of the things i was coming to see was
you do jiu jitsu he goes so i brought my
suit just hopefully you were here and
you came
and uh i just felt good we were talking
spanish for a couple of minutes you know
i got the cuban pulled out of me
i died yeah and i didn't have it again i
didn't have it again for like five years
and now i'm way deep in it again i'm way
deeper than i am and i'm uh my uncle
called last night my uncle that did the
podcast first he's 76
and he goes i made up my [ __ ] mind
but he said all this in spanish yes i
will i'm taking you your wife the kid
my daughter the boys everybody we're
going to cuba next summer
he goes get your passport in order so
now i got to get my passport in order at
least to go to cuba they won't let me go
to canada
but i gotta go like we're gonna go as a
family we're gonna go as one big [ __ ]
we're taking the jew with us too what do
you think you think he'd come back if he
went crazy over that clock though
that's where the uh the the jewish
community was in cuba
yeah yeah they they you know they they
arrive in havana you know from world war
ii you know running away from uh from
hitler poland you know there you go bro
really there's some jews in cuba you're
kidding [ __ ]
if you go to south beach there's like oh
yeah temples everywhere you know cuban
uh jewish temples yeah wow yeah so you
might have to go down there with this
dog we're going to cuba i'm down we're
going first podcast ever from cuba first
podcast there from cuba have you been
moody since and you don't ever wanna
let's see i checked this morning was
still a communist country so no so you
won't go even to perform like these
people no i you know my mom and dad
never went back
they went back to visit my grandmother
and never went back but you know it's
it's
they they sacrificed so much to bring my
brother and me over here you know so
they they'll always express their
not us wanting to go back you know my
brother and me so i i i respect their
wishes yeah how's your brother doing
he's doing good you and your brother the
band now for the first time
well we did we we toured it when you
know with this jeff tate queens right
and it was fun a lot of fun you know we
hadn't toured together
actually we had never toured together
uh we played together in miami a lot and
then later on in new jersey
but uh we had never been in a national
touring band before more international
because we actually got to play in
brazil
and uh
so it was it was definitely a lot of fun
and you know the next tour with queens
right with jeff tate yeah yeah i mean
it's being rebranded as operation mine
crime so i okay okay so i'm not i i i
don't have the timeline of what things
are going to be happening
in the near future but yeah do you still
sing silent liquidity well you're not
allowed to sing that one who jeff the
new band yeah oh yeah it's a beautiful
song and it's awesome okay so we could
do it okay because i thought yeah yeah
yeah i thought they had the same pink
floyd thing going on like jeff tate's
queen's right can't do the old queen no
no no i think they some they have
something to do with operation mind
crime that he does operation mind crime
and empire or something and whatever i
you know i stay out of this you just
don't give a [ __ ] you're like me you
just show up no because you know it has
nothing to do with me right yeah nothing
at all i always tell legal he asked me a
question because i don't even get
involved i just know this yeah i mean
it's simple if it had to do with me yes
i would get involved but it has nothing
to do with me
you're a [ __ ] great guy man i love it
just having you around you ate the
croquette i went to mambo he picked up
some you find out
did you like
my wife got the shredded beef
i liked it it was okay but it wasn't my
mother's my mother's really doped up
with the olives and [ __ ]
but this picadillo is okay
basically the raisins oh my goodness my
mom used to make that picarillo dish
which is chopped meat basically
it's sloppy joe for cubans it's a sloppy
joe but she'd boil the fries
the little potatoes and then fry them
with oh my god in the meat with olives
stopping a couple raisins with some
white rice
stopping a [ __ ] mate but i almost
brought you my butt and you don't
believe that's that's a cuban soda my
tables are cuban soda and iron beer it's
the other one have you ever i haven't
had it but i've seen you he's seen it at
the house the guy with the muscle and
[ __ ] you don't break
i am beer you don't beg you don't [ __ ]
yeah
we were talking about all those cuban
words like nietzsche nietzsche means a
black dude but now you can't say it no
more but nietzsche has even called
themselves
you know in cuba it was wide open they
call themselves niches and you call them
like china like all the chinese chino is
chinese whether they're japanese korean
vietnamese
cambodian they all fall into the one
cuban thing
whatever and if they're arabs no matter
what
whether they're from turkey
that's just the way it is
let me give a shout out to my main
[ __ ] over and on and
making it happen to you i've been
getting a lot of uh twitch lately from
people ordering on it they really enjoy
the alpha brand
the alpha brand i always tell you it's
like going to a chinese restaurant the
pork fried rice sucks you got no
business being there that's their
signature product the alpha brain it
gives you focus it helps you maintain
your [ __ ] awareness and it's got 100
money back guarantee that's how it
starts without it go to on it go to
joeydiaz.net go to the honor box and
press church church and get 10 off your
first order they have the stay on it
program whether you want the hemp force
whether you want the the shroom tech new
moon sport the new moon they got the new
mci coconut for your smoothies trust me
i wouldn't [ __ ] around you're going to
start a new resolution this year
starting now with on it go to honor.com
and press church and get your 10 percent
off and they got to stay on the program
i also want to welcome my main
[ __ ] i love them to death
irondragontv.com okay for all your
classic kung fu movies all the admins
the the tai chi zeros what the [ __ ] is
this
the classic light enter the fat dragon
life of a ninja this company is owned by
nanotech where they sponsor fighters
they sponsor tim kennedy and michael
mcdonald dave foley's a great guy we had
lunch and dinner and uh i really like
what he's doing he's got a great program
over there but it all starts just do me
a favor go to
irondragontv.com right now press either
joey or church in the box and get two
free rentals to start off it's roku tv
correct it's roku so it's any of the
roku's you just they have channels now
so this one focuses on martial arts so
just search iron dragon tv it pops right
up and you put in the cover to get two
free rentals all right and with that you
see what i'm smoking it's a cigar it
tastes great it's smell does it smell
rudy no no but you smell it this is what
i'm talking about this is tremendous you
go to vegas you can blow smoke in the
[ __ ] 21 blackjack dealer's face
go to eat six this is what they have
they have beautiful cigars they have
beautiful e cigarettes 0
8 16 and 24 nicotine milligrams if
you're thinking of quitting smoking for
the new year this is the way to do it
hit e6 i'm telling you right now you get
a 24 smoking for a week and a half then
go to the 16 smoke that for a week and a
half smoke a few joints too then you go
to eight then you go to zero and bam
you're not smoking [ __ ] cigarettes no
more and you maintain with one of these
who's better than you they come in
different flavors and but this is the
baddest [ __ ] they have the cigar
is that called electric cohiba
it's an electric cohiba they get the
smoke from fidel's
bad breath and they put it in here and
[ __ ] like that also to my main brother
what do you wait use cover joey's church
and get 20 off get 20 percent off on
haiti say so jews joey's church get
twenty percent off hit these things
edward gaba they're doing a great job
over there please support these things
you're gonna [ __ ] love it also nailed
it life if you like smoking vapor best
vapor pen in the market tremendous
they're going to send me a script for
something else they just added something
else to the webpage go to nailed it
life.com go to the webpage see what they
got they got t-shirts they got the best
vaper pen in the market if you put in
the box
joey diaz you get 20 off so it's 50
bucks you get it for 40. if anything
happens it breaks down whatever you call
them boom the next day is sent to your
house no [ __ ] drama that's the way
that's customer service at their best
david don't [ __ ] around west new york
cubans where's new york west new york
and the [ __ ] house rudy sargo i
want you to uh
i want to figure out how you get your
schedule to me so we can put it up there
so we could talk about you when the
schedules come close to the united
states maybe we can meet in the city and
they'll be on the cuban food in
minnesota they got good human food you
get to miami much i was just there about
a month ago tremendous isn't it yeah
yeah just to see my folks you know
tremendous yeah
great i went uh three weeks ago but i
watched the other night the whole time i
watched anthony bourdain layover in
miami
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] rudy he went to some tremendous
places but he talked to the most
interesting he talked to some cuban
fishermen
that were in cuban and after the
revolution they came up here and they
continue to do the same thing so all
their buddies their cuban buddies they
just fish all day and bring the same
fish to the same restaurant and whatever
they have like some days they have
buggle some they were saying all the
fish names in spanish i was getting
goosebumps i love all that stuff you
know last time i went to miami i
realized something rudy that
and you can't you can't because of what
we do
but if you're spanish at one point you
gotta live in miami for a month or two
just to
it was different i know some people
don't like it my mother didn't like it
my mother didn't want to be around a
bunch of crying cubans she said
but this last time when i went you pull
over on the streets and they're drinking
coffee
and you go and they ask you if you want
a cup to invite you to a cup for a
quarter whatever it is and it just
i like that i like that thing yeah i
like that it's not starbucks in
starbucks everybody's on their [ __ ]
computers
look trying to who's trying to be the
smartest one in the [ __ ] room and
miami nobody was trying to be the
smartest one in the room they were just
trying to co-exist man
yeah and i hadn't been around in a long
time and i really really enjoyed it so
that's why you know i i grew up there
and thank god you know my
my mom and dad are still with us
but it's a you know they're almost 90.
you know there's that that last
generation
even though i was born in cuba you know
but we're talking about
the last generation that actually left
cuba with their children and sacrificed
everything that they had to give their
children a better life
you know
in freedom
you know because after all that's what
we came here for you know everybody had
jobs over there it's just a matter of
like you know things got screwed up when
communism came in and took everything
away you know
so um all the sacrifices and it's that
generation you know and i it's it's
it's it's it's a bit sad because they
never like in my parents case they they
thought they was just gonna be like you
know we're going to be here in miami for
a few months and then go back to havana
you know because they
they left
our place just like we were going up for
the weekend you know everything stayed
because we couldn't give any of our
belongings to our relatives because you
know the committee defense you know the
the defense committee people were like
you know they were like tell us on us
and
we you know we basically had to sneak
out of our
house in order to get to the airport and
get dressed in somebody else's place so
that our neighbor didn't see us like hey
when you because back in the day you you
wore suit when you flew
you know at a certain time you know
and uh so all of this stuff and then we
we get to the united states and it's
going through the whole you know you
know the whole process of becoming cuban
refugees even till we you know we we
enter legally passports and visas and
sponsor and a little bit
there's a lot of sacrifices you know and
i see that last generation not
fulfilling their dream of going back to
cuba someday because it's just it's you
know every day
you know it's like it ain't gonna happen
you know
it the only way for them to go back to
cuba would be to basically go back
again under another communist country
you know still a communist country so it
it is a bit sad for me to uh to witness
that that their hopes and dreams of that
generation are basically my sister's
there yeah i never really met my sister
or in cuba yeah yeah she stayed she
stayed with the grandmother and got
married in the rest of his [ __ ]
history so i want to do that there's a
couple things i want to do i know the
situation i know it's communist what am
i going to do yeah exactly you know i
might die tomorrow i want to show my
little daughter yeah what
grandmother for the graves there's a
side of me that that part of wants to go
wants to really to go the only reason
you know they're always the only reason
why i wouldn't go is because
it's because of my parents that's that's
the only reason anything else i would
really don't give a [ __ ] you know i just
want to i would do it for my myself you
know just to go back and see where i
went to school where i when i when i
grew up and you know whatever i want to
see the same streets my father walked
yeah i want to see the house with my
like well i grew up i want to see the
school they went to yeah
well i see i want to witness that for
firsthand i want to go back to to walk
the streets i walked when i was when i
was in china and i left i was almost 11
when i left
and i want to walk the same streets if
still there or the same school if the
building's still there because
everything is falling apart you know all
i remember is an ocean really
that's all i remember
closed my eyes
i remember holding my mother's hands as
a little boy and that's all i remember
and then being in new jersey wow that's
it i remember but if you talk to me
about cuba i can't lie to you i don't
remember the streets i don't remember
what i ate
i remember a beach i remember just
looking out into the ocean that's it
that's all i could remember so wow i
love you rudy with all my teachers
thank you thank you for having me oh
please i've been thinking about you for
months and somebody hit me up saying
what are you gonna have rudy and two or
three people kept hitting me i'm just i
gotta get a hold of rudy i know you're
busy i'm gonna be at uh philly helium
this week
and then lee uh we're doing a workshop
next wednesday for a one-man show we're
doing something like a testicle
testaments me and marge gibrani that's
at the ice house we might do a podcast
and mix it up a little bit so
uh that's basically it guys i love you
guys again support on it
irondragontv.com
and nailed it life and we'll be back
tomorrow night at 8 o'clock guys
stay black what do you got lee do you
have a website rudy or twitter or
anything people could yeah twitter
resources twitter facebook
uh
tomorrow's my birthday so if anybody
wants to leave any message i'll leave a
message tomorrow
happy birthday i'm not going to ask you
how old you are 29 uh
the second time plus you know i'll be
i'll be 64.
god bless you rudy yeah next year
i get medicare
and you get 10 off at restaurants well i
think i already do that yeah triple a
yeah triple a and in the deloitte erp
yeah i love you brother thank you very
much thank you
no it's okay and if you guys i just
started my first blog at leessai.com if
you want to check it out i'd appreciate
it
shows brought to you by onyt.com go to
onnit.com and use codeword church to get
10 off of any other great products like
strong bone alpha brain new mood shroom
tech immune trim tech sport that's code
word church to get 10 off
go to
irondragontv.com that's iron dragon tv
it's a no it's a new roku channel with
all of the great martial art movies
all the kung fu movies like it man all
that use code word joey or code word
church and you're gonna get two free
rentals on the new roku channel iron
dragon tv
go to hit esigs.com that's hit the
letter e segs.com
for the best vapor pens on the market go
to that's better tasting longer lasting
the proof is in the vape they have
e-cigarettes and e-cigars for you
different flavor e-cigarettes and
different variations of nicotine in the
e-cigars and in the e-cigs use codeword
joey's church to get 20 off and go to
nailed it life.com that's nailed it
life.com for the premier vapor pen on
the market works with oil and wax use
codeword joey diaz no spaces and you're
get 20 off your order